Kim Kardashian stepped out again last
night there she is headed to her husband
Kanye show in LA and yes the keeping up
with the Kardashian cameras were with
her she's been rolling with armed
security in recent days because it's
Kim's new reality and it all stems from
her robbery in Paris well tonight for
the first time we will hear from the man
held at gunpoint with Kim inside that
French hotel our Jennifer perils
traveled to Paris and learn surprising
new details about that terrifying night
there's of course you know a lot of
people all over the world that are
questioning this basically asking you
know was this a publicity stunt did Kim
know from a reality show no it's not a
reality show and really Kim is very
shocked and I I feel her shock till now
now it says it wasn't fake Abdulrahman
is the key witness in Kim Kardashian's
armed robbery this is his first time
recounting that terrifying night on
camera the media
you know I think they don't know what
happened really his account revealed
three things we hadn't heard before
first we finally got clarity about his
role that night Abdul has been widely
described as a concierge but really he
was more of a night watchman I'm a guard
who who do a job of a receptionist you
have a gun with you at work no your are
in France he says just after 2:00 a.m.
three men came to the door dressed as
police so I opened the door the guys
come by actually they pulled Authority
force and then he put the gun on me he
told me don't look at me that leads to
the second revelation Abdul says one of
the robbers was astounded to learn that
the hotel did not have working security
cameras I told him there is no camera he
was very angry or why he also like a
amazing they are kidding me no coming
right here here's where the story takes
an interesting turn so despite reports
that Kim was targeted specifically
mainly because of the jewels that she
showed off on her social media account
Abdul told me that the robbers actually
came here that night with every
intention to rob all of the eleven
apartments here when they came in to
they say you know where's Kim Kardashian
no no no they don't know her name at all
that's revelation number three Kim and
her jewels were not the primary target
if all the guests was in the hotel they
will are up all the hotel all the flats
and there was in the hotel some
important person air
yes girlfriend yeah Jennifer Lawrence
was maybe two two nights before he says
the robbers forced him to let them into
Kim's room he says Kim was terrified and
begged for her life
so you were handcuffed in front of you
yeah then they went to what did they do
with Kim did they tie her hands up as
well yes also from here
so they tied her ankles together yeah
okay so her hands were tied her her
ankles were tied yes not a tape on her
mouth and the guy was asking for money
raise money money money she believed
that they was there for her wing at that
moment she gave him her being so he puts
a ring in his pocket and then what did
he say well his money money money money
money is so far no suspects after the
incident both Kim and Abdullah were
interviewed by police until early in the
morning Kim left the hotel like 7:00
a.m. yeah did you see her leave yes she
she hacks me and she helped you and I
called her the most important thing is
but you are safe and we are alive that's
it and she left
as for Abdul himself well he told us
that he has quit his job at Hotel and
has plans to move back to his native
Algeria